now that we've chosen a coordinate
system for our runner going along a road
we now want to describe the position
function of that coordinate system with
respect to our choice of origin now the
runner is a non rigid object legs and
arms are moving back and forth so let's
just imagine that there's some fixed
point in the runner at the center and
then let's give a vector so we're going
to draw a vector from above our origin
to that point and this is what we'll
refer to as our position function now
remember every point here has an
x-coordinate so we can now introduce our
position function which we'll call X of
T which is the coordinate location with
respect to the origin this is a function
that will change in time and our
position vector is R of T equals the
position function X of T now remember
this is a vector the position function
is just a quantity that's describing the
location of this point with respect to
the origin
but the unit vector is how we describe
this as a vector and so we write I hat
now X of T is what we call the component
of the position vector remember a vector
has a component and a direction and this
the component is the position function
and that component X of T can be
positive as you see in this particular
case X of T can also be zero that's if
you're located at the origin and if our
runner is on the other side of the
origin X of T can be negative so the
component of the vector of the position
vector can be positive zero or negative
and the direction of the position vector
is the sign of the component times I hat
if the component is negative then we
have a negative I hat the position
vector is pointing backwards in the
minus X direction and if X of T is
positive positive I hat position vector
as shown in this particular case is in
the positive I hat direction so that's
our first vector
the position vector in one-dimensional
motion